the image of a man cursed to forever
hold the earth on his shoulders is one
that many of us may be familiar with but
how many of us actually know the story
behind the man the man this story
centers around is in fact not a man at
all but rather a Titan known as Atlas
and a common misconception is that it's
the earth on his shoulders but he was
actually cursed by Zeus to hold Uranus
the personification of the sky in the
heavens and that is what he bears on his
shoulders he was part of what many
considered to be the second generation
of titans being the son of the Titan II
a pitous and claim any one of the many
daughters of Oceanus making him the
brother to Prometheus Epimetheus and
many Oh tears it was also believed that
Atlas fathered many children a large
portion of them being regarded as nymphs
including the Hesperides Calypso and
Mayor the mother of homies which would
make the messenger called one of Atlas's
grandchildren during the war between the
Titans and the Olympians Atlas and his
brother many odious sided with the
Titans whereas Prometheus and Epimetheus
sided with Zeus but Atlas was believed
to have been one of the main sources of
rebellion against the Olympians
potentially even leading Titans into
battle which is why when the war ended
Zeus made an example of Atlas his
brothers and sisters were banished to
Tartarus but Zeus condemned that list to
stand on the western edge of the earth
and hold the heavens on his shoulders
forever separating Uranus and Gaia it's
because of this that Atlas is often
associated with endurance even sometimes
being called enduring Atlas a name that
is thought to embody his daily struggle
and eternal punishment Atlas was
regarded as the bearer of the heavens
and had a close link to astronomy when
sailors looked to the sky as a tool of
navigation it was their belief that they
were being instructed by Atlas and the
same can be said for farmers when they
attempted to measure the seasons the
roles of navigation and measuring the
seasons were somewhat combined as Atlas
became the God responsible for turning
the heavens on its axis causing the
Stars to rotate and revolve in Homer's
Odyssey Atlas is described as being
responsible for holding the pillars that
separated the heavens from the earth but
in Hesiod's Theogony
he's instead depicted as bearing the
weight of the heavens on his shoulders
the Atlas Mountains located in northwest
Africa in the regions of Morocco Algeria
and Tunisia are often heavily associated
of the Titan it's believed that when the
hero Perseus acquired the head of Medusa
he came across Atlas and when the Titan
glance into the Gorgons eyes he was
turned into an enormous mountain well
this story begins when Gaia gave the
goddess Hera a tree full of golden
apples as a wedding gift
the tree was guarded by alice's
daughters the Hesperides and was in a
location known by very few the titan was
told by an oracle that one day a son of
zeus would find the tree and attempt to
steal the golden apples that he sought
as guarded in order to stop this from
happening he would let no one enter his
land and when Perseus came across Atlas
he denied him any form of hospitality an
action that Perseus of course did not
take too kindly he lifted Medusa's head
above his shoulder showing the Titan and
immediately turned in Atlas into an
enormous mountain range a mountain range
that we now refer to as the Atlas
Mountains perhaps the most famous story
feature in atlas was the role he played
in the 12 labors of Heracles the Greek
hero was tossed by King Eurystheus to
steal some of the golden apples from the
gardens of asperities the apples were
guarded by the serpent night dragon
known as laDawn a foe that Heracles was
advised to avoid by Prometheus who
instead suggested that he asked the
Titan atlas for his assistance in return
for the Titans help
Heracles will take the burden of the
heavens from his shoulders when the
Titan eventually returned he refused to
resume his responsibilities as the
bearer of the heavens he planned to
leave Heracles with the weight of the
heavens on his shoulders by some form of
trickery Heracles convinced the Titans
to swap places under the illusion that
he could ease the strain on Alice's
shoulders but instead Heracles took the
apples and left just as Atlas planned to
leave him there are a few different
variations of the story relating back to
the depictions of Homer's Odyssey in
another variation of the story
Heracles built enormous pillars capable
of holding the heavens freeing Atlas
from his burden and in return the Titan
would acquire the golden apples for
Heracles
Atlas has quite an interest in and
symbolic figure and Greek mythology for
numerous reasons he symbolizes the
hardships that some of us have to endure
on a daily basis and he's stoic M
resilient approach show us that even the
most impossible task of holding the
entire weight of the heavens on one's
shoulders can be possible it's important
not to forget that he also symbolizes
the wrath of Zeus he was one of the main
forces opposing the rule of Zeus and as
a result he was made an extreme example
of warning anyone who dared to oppose
the rule of Zeus and his fellow
Olympians that a similar fate awaits
them it's likely that the ancient Greeks
looked at Atlas as an extremely useful
God he provided sailors of the means of
navigation and a way for farmers to
distinguish between the seasons if I had
to hazard a guess I'd believe that the
ancient Greeks were quite grateful
towards Atlas as many of them could have
believed that without the Titan there'd
be nothing to stop the heavens from
crashing down upon them quite often the
Titans are mentioned scarcely and even
less so after the war but Atlas is one
that we know quite a lot about compared
to the rest and it poses an interesting
question if the Titans would have won
the war would Atlas have assumed the
role similar to that of Zeus order now
it's heightened have challenged him I
look forward to hearing what you guys
think in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
you
[Music]